so where we left off in the last video
vi and myself had posed a mystery to you
we had talked about benford's law and we
asked what is up with benford's law this
idea that if you took just random
countries and took their population and
took the most significant digit in their
population and plotted the numbers the
numbers of countries that their most
significant digit is a one versus a two
versus a three you just had
it was much more likely there would be a
one or that if you took physical
constants of the universe that they're
more most likely to have one as their
most significant digit
and that i wish we had more graphs
because the graphs are fun yes but if
you look at information from the stock
market or yes and then and yes and it
seemed to all follow this curve and what
was
extremely mysterious is where we
finished off the last video was if you
look at pure i would say compounding
phenomenon like like for example the
fibonacci sequence or uh powers of two
that exactly fits the benford
distribution it exactly fits this if you
take all the powers of 2 exactly 30 or i
don't know a little a little bit over 30
percent of those powers of 2 all of the
powers of 2
have one as their most significant digit
a little bit what is this like 17
roughly 17 percent of all of them have
two as their most significant although
in this case there's an infinite number
in every section yes it's harder to
graph but if you want if you wanted if
you wanted to try it out you could take
the first million powers of two and then
find the percentage and that'll probably
give you a pretty good approximation of
things yeah so so that's the so to me
that's that's like less mysterious when
you're looking at i mean on the one hand
wow this fits exactly with mathematics
but it also gives you a really good
handle because you realize all right
there's something here i can actually
take a look you can take a look at it
starts to become something you can dig
deeper in and we said in the last video
we wanted you to pause it and and and
think about why this is happening
because frankly we had to do that the
same thing and and uh a big clue for us
was when we looked at a logarithmic
scale and and we're looking at one right
over here and just to be clear what's
going on in this logarithmic scale is
you see equal spaces on the scale are
powers of 10. so on a linear scale this
would be a 1 and maybe this would be a 2
and then a 3 or if we wanted to say that
this is a 2 you would say this is a 1
this is a 10 this would be a 20 and it
would be a 30 so on and so forth but in
a logarithmic scale equal distances are
are times 10 or in this case if we're
taking powers of 10. so this is 1 to 10
then 10 to 100 then 100 to a thousand
and you see how the numbers in between
fall out that the space between one and
two is pretty big and then two and three
is still pretty big but a little bit
smaller than three and four gets smaller
and smaller smaller until you get to ten
and that's a pretty big clue about
what's going on with benford's law
yeah it seems to match up somehow so
there's a connection here and it
actually turns out and this is actually
a very big clue that this if you take
this area if you take this area right
here as a percentage of this entire area
as as a percentage of this entire area
it's exactly this percentage
it's exactly that percentage there and
if you take this area
as a percentage of that entire it's
exactly this percentage that roughly 17
percent or whatever that number is right
over there so that's a huge clue
yeah or at least for for our powers of
two or fibonacci sequence thing uh for
powers
it definitely makes sense yes for for
any powers and so and and so the logic
is and this is now our biggest clue is
to actually plot the powers of two on a
logarithmic scale like this all right
let's see where they fall all right
let's try it out so 2 to the 0th power
is 1.
2 to the first power is 2 then you get
to 4
then you get 2 8
then you get to 16 which is going to be
someplace around here
then you want to go to 32 which is going
to be someplace around there that's 30
so it's 32 then you want to go to 64.
and so this is 40 50
60 64 is going to be right
right over there and so what you see is
when you plot the powers of 2 on this
logarithmic scale they're equal distance
apart so you you keep you keep stepping
along even if you're plotting on a
linear scale they get further and
further apart yeah actually twice as far
apart every time but if on this scale
right over here they are equally spaced
so what's happening is you have
something that's just equally stepping
along you can imagine even just like
walking along this and if your sidewalk
is shaped like this logarithmic scale
you're just much more
the probability on any given step as you
do many many steps or as you count all
the steps you're going to have many many
more steps that fall into the block
that's between 1 and 2 or between 10 and
20 than you will for example to block
this between 9 and 10. if you just take
a random point along
here you're more likely to fall in a
area starting with one right one of
these areas or you know between exactly
starting with one so between 1 and 2 or
10 and 20 or 100
and that's exactly
so taking equal steps is going to give
you that distribution unless your steps
happen to there's special cases right so
where people walk logarithmically if you
walk if you walk well if you walk from
one to ten if your steps are
uh ten long yes and the spatial case is
yes if you're if you're if your steps
are ten long exactly right but if you're
anything any slight variation away from
that exact thing and then you will
you'll get the distribution all over the
place the benford's distribution then
first distribution this this even though
i think we now understand why it's still
fascinating yeah well this this explains
it for
these number series yes it does not ex
so now we have to somehow figure out how
to connect that right
and and real world information the
general idea also for populations and we
read up a little about it and benford's
distribution tends to work for things
that that grow exponentially like powers
of time
like powers of two and populations grow
exponentially yeah and uh in finance a
lot of things also grow exponentially
yes or or decline exponentially either
way or but it tends to operate
exponentially you keep growing by 10
every year that's an exponential of a
path what's fascinating is physical
constants and we actually aren't 100
sure
no this is still crazy to me this is
this is we only have theories here and
uh
the general idea because you know
physical constants are dependent on the
units you're dealing with uh depending
on on a whole bunch of things uh but but
they are i actually i you know i i'll
i'll i have a few very loose theories uh
but but i'll i'll let y'all think about
that more
okay all right
and so hopefully you all enjoyed this